public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation est l'invité de l'épreuve
de vérité bonsoir stéphane travert en
soi et merci beaucoup d'être avec nous à
ce rendez vous donc de public sénat avec
les échos radio classique i avec l' afp
trois grandes questions vous seront
posées au cours de cette émission 1
êtes vous fier comme nicolas hulot que
la france tienne bon à bruxelles sur le
glyphosate un refus de cinq années de
plus de l'herbicide vous répondrez à
jean francis pécresse de les
agriculteurs sont ils condamnés dans
notre pays à la misère ils sont nombreux
on le sait à ne pas pouvoir vivre de
leur travail sujets qu'abordera jérémy
marrot 3 les six mois maintenant de la
présidence macron comment convaincre les
français d'un changement positif vous le
dirai à oriane mancini et nous
découvrirons le sondage opinionway pour
l'épreuve de vérité vous verrez
résultats contradictoires sur cette
question d'un premier bilan des six mois
mais d'abord une toute première question
d'actualité
[Musique]
la croissance repart en europe y compris
en france d'ailleurs mai mais moins
fortement en revanche le commerce
extérieur français plonge le trou sera
cette année de quelques 60 milliards
d'euros faiblesse de l'industrie mais
aussi de l'agriculture même si le solde
est positif on exporte moins on importe
plus qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas ou plus moi je
vois deux choses d'abord vous avez parlé
de la reprise oui il y à la reprise de
l'économie française et nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui
eh bien ils consomment mais ils
consomment des biens de dire de première
consommation et des biens qui sont
produits à l'étranger ce qui crée ce ce
décalage avec ce que nous nous pouvons
exporter
et puis sur l'agriculture il y a nous
payons bien évidemment les effets de la
très mauvaise récolte de 2016
et aujourd'hui nous devons travailler à
rendre nos exploitations plus plus
compétitive devons travailler sur la
bannière france monte en gamme
travailler sur ce qui fait la qualité du
modèle france la qualité de la ferme
france est-ce que ça n'est pas
contradictoire montée en gamme et être
plus compétitif par exemple est-ce que
vous êtes favorable à une solution
peut-être pour faire face à la
concurrence internationale
les fameuses fermes usines comme celle
dont on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui en
saône-et-loire le commissaire enquêteur
a dit son opposition est ce que vous
vous y êtes favorable oui ou non
écoutez il y à aujourd'hui en france des
modèles agricoles des systèmes agricoles
et moi je n'oppose pas les jeunes oppose
pas les systèmes
je crois que ces systèmes ils peuvent
cohabiter dès lors où les règles de
sécurité sanitaire sont respectés aux
dés lors où les conditions du bien être
animal sont respectés vous l'avez vers
4000 bovins cc oui mais dès lors où
cette ferme présente toutes les
conditions de sécurité et mais aussi
présente toutes les conditions qui vont
permettre à ce que les exploitations et
les excuses autres exploitations puisse
trouver le modèle économique qui va bien
et qui permettra aux données pour on ne
peut pas répondre ce jour où je suis con
des conditions sont réussis les
conditions vous
et quand des champions bien évidemment
là ne sont pas opposés à ce type de
modèle parce que je ne veux pas opposer
le modèle agricole
il y à des philosophies il y à
l'anarchie l'idée c'est que cela puisse
trouver des débouchés économiques qui
puisse créer de l'emploi faire de
l'information et valoriser les
productions corps alors si c'est ça qui
est important
ces fermes usines et existe notamment en
allemagne on le sait est ce que les
éleveurs aujourd'hui doivent craindre le
c'est à l'accord commercial de l'union
européenne avec le canada est ce que là
selon vous c'est un risque d'importation
massive de viande bovine en france au
détriment de la nôtre non je ne le crois
pas pour la bonne et simple raison c'est
parce que nous avons mis en place un
plan d'action mobilisation et control
contrôle de ceux qui rentrent sur le
territoire français et je puis vous dire
que lorsque l'on regarde les dernières
importations de viande canadienne sur le
territoire français elles sont très
faibles par rapport à ce qui était
contenu dans l'accord dans l'accord
précédent est aujourd'hui un nouvel un
nouvel acquéreur ouverte grand partage
avec vous il ya un nouvel accord mais il
y a aussi ce que nous avons proposé avec
le gouvernement ce plan d'action qui
doit nous permettre de contrôler ce qui
rentre sur notre territoire et nous
n'accepterons pas sur le parce qu'il ya
le principe de réciprocité que ce que
nous ne produisons pas sur notre
territoire
parce que les conditions de production
ne correspondent pas à ce que nous
souhaitons en termes de traçabilité et
de sécurité puissent venir sur notre
territoire et les choses sont claires là
dessus très bien à la suite de l'épreuve
de vérité avec une autre grande question
d'actualité c'est jean francis pécresse
le directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique qui nous rejoint
[Musique]
françois argent français bonsoir michel
bonsoir stéphane travert alors il n'y a
pas eu accord aujourd'hui à bruxelles
sur le renouvellement du glyphosate cet
herbicide très contesté la france
demande toujours un délai une
reconduction pour trois ans maximum
est ce que comme nicolas hulot qu'on va
écouter vous vous dite fière de cette
position française on écoute tout de
suite et vous réagissez après je
contente la france ait maintenu sa
position
ce qui est important là dedans c'est que
on est quand même passé en quelques
semaines
d'une idée qu'on allait reporter sans
autres prescriptions l'utilisation du
glyphosate sur dix ans alors vaut comme
si de rien n'était a maintenant une
prise en compte un peu plus sérieuse qui
non seulement veut raccourcir
considérablement les délais de
réalisation
mais surtout c'est ça qui est important
parce que c'est pour moi l'essentiel à
sortir tout ça d'un plan pour
reprogrammer pas simplement la sortie
d'une chose at en réalité maintenant je
pense que chacun a intégré qu'il va
falloir qu'on commence ce très
sérieusement a programmé la sortie de la
plupart des pesticides
alors est ce que vous êtes fier de cette
position française moi je serais heureux
et fier lorsque l'europe aura réussi à
se mettre d'accord
et lorsque nous serons effectivement
dans la sortie effective de ce produit
et lorsque nous aurons trouvé les moyens
d'accompagner des agriculteurs c'est ça
la question qui se poserait la question
c'est la journée aussi 2010 la question
qui se pose c'est c'est une décision
européenne c'est une belle robe bleu roi
sont aujourd'hui est ce si ce n'est des
fêtes pour l'europe aujourd'hui mais
c'est une défaite pour l'europe parce
que l'europe n'a pas pu trouver une
position 14 pays se sont voté pour
contre l'organisation à 54,16 la
dernière fois nous la position du
gouvernement elle est claire c'est
trouver les conditions d'une sortie
acceptable pour les agriculteurs et
faire en sorte que nous puissions les
accompagner dans cette danse est sorti
et aujourd'hui nous sommes sur cette
ligne et moi je serais heureux lorsque
nous aurons trouvé les moyens de cette
sortie acceptable
et lorsque le report a réussi à se
mettre d'accord donc il faut que l'on
continue à travailler à aller chercher
des alliés parce que notre objectif
final et je le partage avec nicolas
hulot c'est bien évidemment la sortie
des des pesticides mais aussi
l'accompagnement et tout le monde vient
là dessus les ong comme l'ensemble des
acteurs viennent sur cette position de
soutien autres ils vont nous attendre à
dire de cette pole est ce que vous êtes
en train de nous dire que la france doit
transiger sur la question et accepter ce
délai de cinq ans qui est assez
communément
me que même les écologistes au parlement
européen avait accepté d'ailleurs avait
avait avalisé
oui devait cette position de la vodka
rang qu'ils pouvaient mais moi j'avais
quand j'avais proposé le 21 septembre
dernier une période de cinq ans c'était
une période de cinq ans non pas pour
ensuite porter un autre renouvellement
c'était une période de cinq ans aura vu
aucun putting out une sortie et moi je
suis pour la sortie dans cinq ans
aujourd'hui quand aujourd'hui la
position du gouvernement
vous l'avez vous de la vente ces trois
inventions de matignon ces quatre ans
ces quatre ans la position du
gouvernement a lancé la position du
gouvernement défend un théâtre en sept
mois ce qu'on a devant la tradition du
gouvernement et est sûre et sur quatre
ans mon collègue a précisé qu' il le
souhaitait que cela puisse faire voler
le la dès 3 ans oui nicolas hulot tout à
fait mais aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas
d'accord ce n'est pas une question de ne
pas être d'accord monsieur la question à
braga ce n'est pas pas question
aujourd'hui c'est que la france n'est
pas toute seule la france n'agisse pas
seule la faire à cette fois c'est ça il
faut faire des compromis a commencé doit
aller chercher des alliés elle doit
aller chercher des alliés l'objectif moi
ce qui m'importe c'est que lorsque l'on
aura décidé la temporalité le tempo de
sortie de ce produit c'est comment nous
accompagnons les agriculteurs et ceux
qui sont les utilisateurs de ce type de
produits c'est la seule chose qui
m'intéresse c'est la seule chose qui
m'importe moi je ne fais pas de de
pseudo je dirais histoire sur un an de
plus un an de moins ce qui m'importe
c'est que demain et c'est là qu'elle
convoite à 1 qu'elle sera que l'on veut
mais nous ne sommes pas tout seul à
voter quelle sera la position de
l'europe lors du prochain vote il y a
faisons un peu de pédagogie sur 7 sur
cette affaire à la fin de chaque fois à
la fin du mois on va reproposer voilà
une nouvelle un nouveau calendrier de
sortie soit l'europe considère qu' il
n'ya pas comment dire de position
commune et à ce moment là le produit
tombe en interdiction
au 31 décembre le 15 les dealers oui
enfin en décembre 2000
2010 est hélas il n'y aura plus que les
18 mois d'écoulement d'autorisation pour
écouler les stocks est là et bien là
l'entreprise qui gère ce type de produit
aura la possibilité ou non si elles le
souhaitent de redéposer un dossier
mais ça ça la concerne et ensuite si la
commission décide de faire une
proposition à trois ans à 4 ans nous
verrons il faudra trouver ou à 5 ans
position il faudra c'est ça quand il
faudra regarder mais ce qui m'intéresse
moi c'est qu'elle est la peau qu'elle
sera là la proposition est ce que c'est
une proposition de sortie au derme de 4
ans ou cinq ans et où est ce que c'est
une proposition d'extension de
l'autorisation qui existe actuellement
parce qu'il ya aussi cette question
alors est ce n'est pas la même
différence c'est quoi là je ne parle que
de ça sera dans cinq ans on arrête et
l'autre solution ou c'est une extension
oui enfin d'arrêt au terme de cette
période c sas nos voisins allemands nos
voisins allemands par exemple avait
proposé trois ans un mais trois ans une
extension là une extension à
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché qui
existait déjà
moi ce qui m'intéresse ce n'est pas
cette pseudo polémique sur trois ou
quatre mois de plus
c'est comment est-ce qu'on sort d'abord
de ce débat qui continue à empoisonner
la vie politique aujourd'hui elle avait
des agriculteurs la vie des agriculteurs
justement la fnsea ce soir elle dénonce
une pétaudière 1 et on peut pas vivre
avec ces atermoiements dit le premier
syndicat des écoles a aimé mais aussi la
pose de la faute sur le gouvernement
parce que on a entendu des choses on
entend des choses contradictoires de 3 5
ans et en quatre ans vous êtes aussi un
peu dans les contradictions perpétuel
non
les positions elles sont claires c'est
qu'elle temporalité nous devons trouver
et comme je voulais dit la france n'est
pas seule elle ne décide pas seul
et donc nous devons trouver des alliés
il ya ce travail ce travail à ce
compromis est ce que la fnsea dit ce
soir la perdrière ce que je disais tout
à l'heure c'est que moi je suis triste
que l'europe n'ait pas su dégager une
position commune qui nous permettent de
sortir une fois pour toutes de ce débat
et ensuite de pouvoir travailler sur les
gorges et dan bigras la substitution et
de travailler sur le plan de sortie dont
ont besoin les agriculteurs
soyons pragmatiques vous êtes quoi ont
besoin les agriculteurs qui utilisent
aujourd'hui ce produit c'est d'avoir un
plan de sortie qui soit efficace qui les
accompagnent
c'est vers quel modèle nous allons les
accompagner quelles nouvelles pratiques
agronomiques
ils vont demain employés pour cultiver
leur sol c'est cela l'essentiel du d la
caisse qui existe comme alternative
précisément à cet herbicide le
glyphosate
on lit dans la presse qu'il est ce qu il
existerait un certain nombre de
d'alternative et notamment bio est ce
que c'est vrai oui moi je lui aussi
comme vous la presse et
certains nous disent qu'il existe des
années de grève bio moi là dessus je
n'ai pas moi je m'appuie sur la science
et et le droit comme je le dis toujours
et je ne m'appuie que là dessus
maintenant c'est à l'ancienne c'est aux
instituts techniques c'est à la
recherche de dire si ces produits
peuvent être ou non homologué ce n'est
pas à moi de le dire comme ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
est ce que les agriculteurs sont sont
assez respectueux de l'environnement
aujourd'hui dans notre pays on voit que
par exemple alors on a fait un sondage
avec avec opinionway dont on parlera
après mais on va le site est haute plus
la qualité des dépôts en france voilà
par exemple on a été mis en cause par un
parent la part le précisément l'europe
peu là dessus qu'est ce qu'on fait comme
l'effort pour pour améliorer la qualité
des eaux
vous savez j'étais tout à l'heure avant
de venir ici avec les représentants des
eaux de baignade à le nommer j'entends
bien mais les représentants des
ostréiculteurs mais c'est important
parce que eux aussi ils surveillent la
qualité des eaux sur le littoral parce
que ça dépend aussi de ce que l'on fait
à côté sur sur les sols sont les ai vus
vous dire les agriculteurs aujourd'hui
les producteurs
ce sont les premiers concernés par les
changements climatiques ce sont les
premiers acteurs du développement
durable ce sont les premiers acteurs de
la transformation écologique des
systèmes
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs ils sont
soucieux de la qualité des sols regard
des leçons d'ajustement opinionway on a
posé cette question diriez vous
qu'aujourd'hui en france les
agriculteurs sont respectueux de
l'environnement et bien 39 % de oui
seulement et il ya 59 % donnons donc là
manifestement l'image des agriculteurs à
changer en matière de mobilier ou de
défense de l'environnement sauvage ce
vol ah ça oui monsieur woerth parce que
moi je n'accepte pas que de façon
générale
alors qu'on a besoin de rassembler alors
qu'on a besoin d'emmener tout le monde
on a besoin d'emmener les agriculteurs
mais aussi on a besoin d'emmener nos
concitoyens vers un mieux disant
environnementale vers des pratiques plus
écologiques
et bien moi je j'ai du mal à accepter
que l'on puisse en permanence
mais estimé le travail des agriculteurs
j'ai du mal que l'on puisse en
permanence faire en sorte que les
agriculteurs soient stigmatisées
aujourd'hui moi je rencontre beaucoup
d'agriculteurs dans les sorties que je
fais sur sur le terrain et je puis vous
dire que la plupart d'entre eux
aujourd'hui parce que ils ont suivi des
parcours de formation qui lisons qui
leur ont appris à mieux gérer la qualité
de leurs sols
je puis vous dire que sur ces sujets là
ce sont des acteurs majeurs et qu'ils
sont très précautionneux des produits
d'abord les emplois et qu'ils ont tous
envie de bien et la marne et de laisser
une une trace propre en terme
environnemental sur les terres qu'ils
cultivent il ya un plan en cours
justement qui s'appelle le plan ecophyto
2018 tout à fait dix doigts je crois
permettre de réduire de 50 % la quantité
de pesticides dans les sols à l'horizon
2018 de l'année prochaine ou est-ce
qu'on en est est ce que vous reconduire
et ce plan jusqu'à 2025
oui il a il était en deux parties la
première partie du plan ecophyto qui
avait été lancé par mon prédécesseur
stéphane stéphane le foll
c'est dominique potier qui porte ce plan
ecophyto et bien évidemment il faut
continuer à travailler d'ailleurs un bon
nombre de résultats sont plutôt
satisfaisants sur ce plan ecophyto il
faut continuer à travailler à aller plus
loin et bien évidemment moi je souhaite
m'inscrire dans ce plan ecophyto et
continuer à le faire évoluer
vous ne voyez pas vous ne sentez pas une
crise de confiance entre les français et
leurs agriculteurs aujourd'hui vous n'y
a pas une forme de défiance sur la
qualité de ce que de leur alimentation
mais les les consommateurs et les
français
chacun d'entre nous et est soucieux de
la qualité et de la traçabilité de ceux
qui le suivent ils consomment et je
crois que on doit former un pacte avec
les consommateurs et les agriculteurs
quels que soient les systèmes agricoles
dans lesquels ils évoluent nous devons
travailler et promouvoir plus de qualité
nous devons travailler à mieux segmenter
les
les productions nous devons travailler à
faire en sorte que cette qualité soit au
rendez vous de la demande sociale de nos
de nos concitoyens et c'est comme ça que
l'on va réconcilier à la fois nos que
les concitoyens et le monde le monde
rural moi je n'accepte pas qu'il puisse
y avoir cette espèce de coupures ou
cassure entre ce qu'on appellerait les
urbains d'un côté et les ruraux de
l'autre et moi je suis là pour être un
ensemblier essayer de faire en sorte que
les uns et les autres se parle et que
l'on puisse monter en qualité et faire
en sorte que l'on puisse réussir
ensemble
les députés ont prolongé aujourd'hui en
commission l'aide au maintien à
l'agriculture biologique un parce que
ces budgets ont été rognés 1
du budget gouvernemental non à rester
toute la polémique du moment et tout ça
est ce que vous allez rétablir ces aides
mais ces aides je n'ai pas lire et à que
les états supprimés elles ne sont pas
versées le gers et j'ai dû faire
n'arrivent plus dans les exploitations
ce n'est pas vrai j'ai dû faire un
transfert au coeur de l'été du pilier
inverse le pilier 2 qui a été très
commentée pour financer li chn
rapidement pédagogie sur la bio oui mais
voyez vous la question que vous posez
aujourd'hui elle elle porte sur ce qui
peut nous opposer avec les les membres
les associations qui promeuvent le bio
aujourd'hui je n'ai rien supprimés à
nous continuons à soutenir le je dirais
la mise en duo la conversion bien
évidemment nous avons dans le plfr
adopté un crédit d'impôt qui permet
aujourd'hui aux agriculteurs bio et 6 de
cela dont vous voulez parler qui permet
aux agriculteurs bio de pouvoir et bien
financer leurs activités financer leurs
projets d qui était de la responsabilité
de l'état ont été transférées aux
régions et discutons n'arrivent plus
dans les enclaves où les rassurer je les
rassure et moi je veux les rassurer en
ayant investi dans la centenaire au mal
et non parce que il faut dire des choses
avec avec la réalité non parce qu'on ne
peut pas laisser dire des choses fausses
évidemment on est hors de question de
dire que les aides n'arrivent pas dans
les exploitations ce n'est pas vrai il y
a les aides pac toussaint oui mais il y
a d'abord un impact sur lequel nous
avons travaillé les aides mike qui
arrivent dans les exploitations puisque
nous respectons le calendrier que nous
avions données et sur les aides
bioconversion crédit d'impôt nous sommes
au rendez vous est au rendez vous on
verra si vos propos rassure les haricots
blancs jouent le haut est on le souhaite
aussi pour eux et pour ce qu'on a dans
notre assiette merci jean francis à six
places et de l'épreuve de vérité avec
jérémy marot de la fp qui nous rejoint
l'épreuve de vérité avec la fff et
jérémy bonsoir bonsoir
stéphane travert je voulais vous vous
rappelez deux chiffres que vous
connaissez sans doute parker au sujet
des agriculteurs tout d'abord 50 % des
agriculteurs ont touché moins de 350
euros par mois en 2016 sas et un chiffre
de la mutualité sociale agricole
également entre 2013 et 2015
le revenu annuel moyen des agriculteurs
a chuté de 30% alors est ce que cette
paupérisation est une fatalité est elle
inéluctable et vous ministre de
l'agriculture que pouvez vous promettre
à ses agriculteurs
à la fin du quinquennat je ne crois pas
que ce soit inéluctable
nous avons posé des diagnostics pendant
la campagne électorale
oui le monde agricole traverse des
crises et ils traversent des crises
importantes des crises climatiques des
crises sanitaires qui ont emporté de
nombreuses exploitations et aujourd'hui
nous avons mis en place les états
généraux de l'alimentation pour recréer
de la valeur
redonner de la confiance à notre système
agricole faire en sorte que les
agriculteurs puissent demain vivre
décemment de leur travail retrouve du
revenu et c'était l'objet des états
généraux de l'alimentation que nous
avons nous avons sur lesquels nous avons
travaillé avec le président de la
république et l'ensemble du gouvernement
parce que aujourd'hui nous avons besoin
à la fois de retrouver de la
compétitivité dans les exploitations
nous avons besoin de leur transmettre de
l'innovation pour améliorer cette
compétitivité
nous avons besoin de former nos
agriculteurs les former à de nouvelles
pratiques agronomiques les former sur
les nouvelles techniques d'élevage les
formes et aussi à la gestion des
entreprises c'est pourquoi dans le
budget que j'ai présenté au parlement
j'avais mis un accent particulier sur la
formation et je crois que c'est en
construisant ce rapport nouveau de
confiance entre les producteurs les
distributeurs et les transformateurs que
nous avons la capacité je pense à
pouvoir changer le paradigme et fait en
sorte que notre agriculture demain soit
plus compétitive
au rendez-vous des défis qui l'attendent
alors il ya une attente qui est très
très forte en asie monde agricole on va
écouter la présidente de la fnsea
christiane lambert il vous interpelle
monsieur le ministre vous demande d'agir
dans ce bras de fer entre bien sûr les
producteurs et les distributeurs les
négociations commerciales commence on
écoute les vous répondez monsieur le
ministre très vite fait signer la charte
d'engagements des acteurs de filière
pour respecter de meilleures conditions
dans les négociations commerciales
monsieur maquereau a promis une loi elle
n'interviendra qu'au premier semestre et
négociation commerciale commence en ce
moment c'est très compliqué la pression
est très forte pour baisser encore les
prix
il faut que vous obteniez l'engagement
de tous les acteurs qui vont se
comporter différemment où en êtes vous
on vous demandera de changer les
comportements et notamment les méthodes
commerciales
moi je je souscris pleinement à ce que
dit madame lambert dents sur ce sujet
nous avons effectivement une charte
d'engagement et je puis vous dire que
jeudi dernier j'avais autour de la table
au ministère de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation
j'avais les cinq organisations
syndicales
j'avais les représentants des industries
agroalimentaires j'avais les
représentants de la distribution
ils étaient presque tous là les
représentants de la de la distribution
et nous sommes tombés d'accord pour la
signature d'une charte d'engagements sur
des pratiques nouvelles c'est
l'inversion de la construction du prix
c'est revenir à ce qui fait l'essence
même de l'esprit des états généraux de
l'alimentation c'est tenir compte de la
feuille de route que nous a donnée le
président de la république le 11 octobre
dernier lorsqu'il est venu à régis pour
parler de l'agriculture il avait fait un
discours puissant effort sur
l'agriculture et cette charte
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de la
finaliser parce que il manquait encore
quelqu'un autour de la table il manquait
michel edouard leclerc et je les
rencontrais et aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans la discussion pour faire en sorte
que tout le monde soit là parce que je
souhaite que tout le monde tous les
acteurs de la distribution de la
transformation et de la production soit
autour de la table pour signer cette
charte c'est en bonne voie et nous
sommes en train d'y travailler
madame lambert le sait le sait très bien
puisque son mari inflation freinant call
et d'autres honte
soyez avec nous pour l'élaboration de
cette de cette charte
les rapports sont compliquées avec la
grande distribution vous dit et on a
tendu à michel edouard leclerc
nous nous les rapports ne sont pas
compliqué il y à il ya de la discussion
aujourd'hui on rappelle le bras quand
même où le salaire réel mais tout dépend
de quoi on parle pour la signature de la
charte par exemple je n'ai eu à tordre
le bras de personnes chacun est venue de
son plein gré et la relaxe et la réunion
s'est très bien passé vous savez on a
vécu quelque chose d'historique la
semaine dernière au ministère de
l'agriculture
on a mis autour de la table des gens qui
ne se parlaient plus des gens qui ne
savaient plus travailler ensemble la
réunion s'est très bien passé dans un
excellent climat
chacun put a pu faire valoir son point
de vue etc
mais l'essentiel c'est que nous ayons
trouvé un débouché politique est un
débouché moral sur ce que nous
souhaitons faire et en même temps vous
vous évoquez le discours d' emmanuel
macron il a demandé aussi aux filières
de se prendre en main il a demandé aux
filières elle même de formuler des
propositions qui doivent être formulées
mi décembre
je colle au 10 décembre pour le 10
décembre où en êtes vous où en sont ces
filières sur ces propositions je crois
qu'un point d'étape doit être faire très
prochainement dans les filières nous les
avons reçus pour parler avec elle de la
méthode sur lac sur laquelle ils
pourraient ils pourraient travailler
pour donner le guide je dirais pour fait
nous faire des propositions qui devront
être restituées le 10 décembre prochain
là nous sommes en face des réunions des
réunions techniques
je recevrai les filières la semaine
prochaine une par une dans mon bureau je
les verrai individuellement les unes et
les autres parce que pour faire le point
à mi parcours pour voir où ils en sont
pour voir comment est ce que nous
progressons sur un certain nombre de
sujets parce que nous avons besoin pour
le 10 décembre de pouvoir transmettre au
président de la république
l'ensemble du travail issu de la
réflexion des filières pour ensuite et
bien prendre les engagements que l'etat
sera prêt il n'y a pas un exemple là qui
vient contrarier vos roues paroles
apaisantes sinon rassurante monsieur le
ministre je parlais du beurre le gunner
qui a disparu de certains rayons et on
dit que c'est un énorme bluff en fait la
vérité c'est que les distributeurs
justement monsieur leclerc
et les autres ne veulent pas payé le bon
prix du beurre alors là c'est bien quand
même le fait que c'est toujours le
peut-être le pot de terre contre le pot
de fer
non mais justement vous savez dans la
dans l'inversion de la
contractualisation
là nous avons eu un cas d'école
particulier avec le beurre d'abord il
n'y a pas de pénurie de beurre s'il a pu
manquer du beurre dans les magasins
c'est parce que il ya eu des achats de
précaution beaucoup d'achats de
précaution qui se sont fréquents sur
madère les consommateurs et bien au lieu
d'acheter une plaquette de beurre comme
il en avait l'habitude les ont achetés
par quatre ou cinq
et moi je dis aux gens de ne pas stocker
en plus le beurre en qu'il ait mis au
congélateur c'est pas c'est pas la
meilleure manière de le conserver et de
le manger et de le déguster après c'est
un normand qui vous le dit mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que sur le beurre
nous avons demandé à ce que chacun
prenne ses responsabilités les
distributeurs prennent leur
responsabilité je sais qu'il ya des
discussions en cours
ce sont des discussions qui ne sont pas
toujours qui ne sont pas toujours facile
mais je crois que nous allons arriver à
un point de sortie parce que c'est
nécessaire et moi j'y mets tout mon
poids politique là dedans parce que le
ministère de la culture il est là aussi
moteur pour inciter les uns et les
autres à trouver les voies du compromis
et nous avons besoin de trouver ces voix
de compromis et je puis vous dire que
manqueront pas de beurre et un certain
nombre de grands de grandes surfaces et
de groupes de la distribution ont déjà
passé des trains des trains de hausse
ont accepté du moins il est train de
hausses des transformateurs donc je ne
vois pas pourquoi
demain les rayons ne serait pas regarder
de ce prêt mais vous faites des des
états généraux de l'alimentation en
france c'est très bien mais
l'agriculture française est aussi
ouverte sur le monde tributaire du du
monde extérieur d'ailleurs on a vu la
semaine dernière que les exportations de
foie gras ont repris ses seins vers le
vers le japon qu'en est il de la viande
bovine vers la turquie
voyez qu'il ya des bonnes nouvelles
aussi c'est à dire que la france parce
qu'elle a su faire un gros travail sur
le plan sanitaire a su démontrer que
elle était totalement safe comme on dit
sur de suite à l'épisode de grippe
aviaire est donc le japon a ré ouvert
les portes pour le marché de la volaille
et du foie gras demain
la turquie va faire de même pour les
importations de lait de viande bovine
sur son territoire c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour la filière bovine
française parce que nous savons que la
turquie est très très attaché à la
qualité de la filière bovine française
j'ai pu rencontrer la filière bovine
européenne lundi dernier à bruxelles
avec là dans le cadre de la copa cogeca
et je peux vous dire que là aussi il ya
des attentes fortes et que ceci est
plutôt une bonne douche dans certaines
filières pâtissent de la déprime des
cours mondiaux et ce qu'il faut à ce
moment-là s'organiser plus fortement au
niveau européen quitte à créer des états
généraux de l'alimentation européen on
sait qu emmanuel macron est très friand
de ce genre d'initiatives mais tout à
fait c'est une initiative que nous
allons prendre puisque nous avons
souhaité nous souhaitons exporter nos
états nos états généraux et faire en
sorte que nous puissions avoir des
séances au niveau européen pour partager
notre expérience et je peux vous dire
que bon nombre de nos partenaires et de
mes homologues ministres d'agriculture
en europe sont très intéressés par la
démarche qui est la nôtre actuellement
dernière question à mesurer mais sur le
quotidien des agriculteurs on parle
beaucoup de leur porte monnaie mais on a
aussi l'actualité qui sont émaillés
malheureusement deux faits divers de
suicide des agriculteurs
on parle moins de la prévention des
risques psychosociaux
qu'est ce que vous vous pouvez mettre en
place leur proposait justement pour
éviter que ces faits divers se
reproduise bien sûr il y a on le déplore
il ya toujours beaucoup trop de suicide
dans le monde agricole du fait de la de
la dureté de la difficulté des
conditions de travail des conditions
économiques et il ya des associations
qui font un travail magnifique
formidable pour soutenir les éleveurs en
difficulté et moi ce que je crois c'est
que il faut aller prendre les choses à
la racine c'est-à-dire détecter les
difficultés dès qu'elle arrive et faire
parler les gens
pour éviter que des des drames ne puisse
de puisse arriver et donc c'est faire en
sorte que les agriculteurs ne soit pas
ne soit pas seul c'est qu'il puisse
travailler entre eux qu'ils puissent se
regrouper justement pour partager ce qui
fait la joie de leur métier mais ce qui
fait aussi ses difficultés concrètement
là vous en remettez aux associations en
rythme non pas que mais les associations
mais nous avons la capacité à pouvoir
aussi soutenir le travail d'un certain
nombre d'entre elles et le ministère de
l'agriculture il est là aussi pour
accompagner un certain nombre de
dispositifs des dispositifs sociaux
d'une part mais d'autre part accompagner
les associations sur des projets
particuliers bien évidemment bouras et
une petite question je vais pas vous
demander de rouvrir tout le dossier du
loup vous en avez longuement parlé
aujourd'hui au sénat mais ce que vous
soutiendrez les éleveurs qui tuerait
éventuellement les prédateurs une espèce
protégée est ce que vous les soutiendrai
certains sont prêts à le faire vous avez
cité les prédations dans certains
départements et de 100 attaques parfois
alors est ce que vous le soutiendrez
vous verrez là moi je soutiens les
éleveurs
oui parce que j'ai bien conscience que
ce sont des fils saadi sont créés a valu
les louanges du durée moi je crois que
il faut revenir sur cette question à la
gestion de la pression de l'après
d'assurer c'est tout refaire le dossier
c'est là où c'est difficile
eh bien il faut pouvoir les aider à
travers des mesures prises sur les
territoires et laisser faire les
territoires merci beaucoup
jérémy dernière partie de l'épreuve de
vérité on va parler de politique
au sens plus large maintenant avec
orianne mancini de public sénat qui
arrive
[Musique]
bonsoir rien à votre question qui
s'appuie sur bas sur la deuxième
question de notre sondage exclusif
opinionway exactement bonsoir monsieur
mais voilà cela fait aussi mois
maintenant qu emmanuel macron est arrivé
à l'elysée avec notre partenaire
opinionway vous allez le voir nous avons
posé la question aux français pour
savoir ce qu'il pensait de la situation
de la france depuis l'élection d'
emmanuel macron va regarder ensemble les
résultats 50 % pensent que la situation
n'a pas changé 31% qu'elle s'est
détériorée et seulement à 18 % trouvent
qu'elle s'est améliorée
comment convaincre les français stéphane
travert part de la pédagogie expliquer
ce que l'on fait pourquoi on le fait ou
on veut emmener les français et ses skis
emmanuel macron et l'ensemble du
gouvernement fait jour après jour après
jour nous avons je dirais faut de la
sérénité
faut pas avoir d'états d'âme il faut
faire ce que nous avons dit et dire ce
que nous faisons et c'est ce à quoi ce
gouvernement s'emploie depuis qu'il est
en responsabilité et moi je regarde ce
sondage en disant qu' on a fait presque
un an et demi deux ans de campagne
comment pourrions-nous en six mois avec
un mois et demi quasiment consacrée aux
élections législatives et à la
préparation de la future majorité
répondre à 25 ans ou 30 ans d'échec et
je crois que notre action elle s'inscrit
elle s'inscrit dans la durée et bien
évidemment que nous souhaitons que les
résultats arrivent le plus vite possible
et on le on le voit à travers la reprise
qui qui est là on le voit à travers les
messages que nous envoie les pays de
l'union européenne
la voix de la france elle est entendu la
voix de la france elle est très attendue
aujourd'hui
et donc ce sont des messages de
confiance on a besoin d'avoir cette
capacité à entraîner les gens sur nos
projets et leur expliquer doctement ce
que nous faisons et pourquoi nous
faisons libéré et protégés cela reste
toujours 2010 dit aux français qu'il
faut être patient que ça prendra du
temps c'est un peu ce que disait bruno
le maire ce matin dans les échos aussi
sur le chômage oui mais moi je tenais
seront l'on attend
mais moi je comprends l'impatience des
français cela fait des années qu'on leur
demande d'être patient justement est-ce
que vous évoquez également peut-être
leur demande d'adhésion à la
personnalité au style de gouvernement du
chef de l'état vous savez sur le style
de gouvernance du chef de l'état chef de
l'état il assume et il remplit
parfaitement sa fonction il fait
autorité comme chef de l'état il incarne
aujourd'hui la politique qu'il a proposé
devant les français pendant l'élection
présidentielle
il fédère il a su fédérer des gens qui
venaient de parcours et des espaces
différents campo est comme moi et comme
d'autres est aujourd'hui cette force là
et bien elles doivent se traduire en
actes
nous travaillons pour les français nous
travaillons pour la france est
aujourd'hui à travers les premières
mesures que nous avons pris libéré
permettre à l'économie de se mettre au
service de nos concitoyens et protégés
ensuite faire en sorte que nos
concitoyens puissent voir leur pouvoir
d'achat augmenter à travers un certain
nombre de mesures remettre les gens dans
l'emploi comment traiter la question du
chômage de masse et comment répondre aux
inégalités
vous parliez de vous parler de pédagogie
tout à l'heure est ce que c'est un
problème de pédagogie
ou est ce que c'est le fait que la
majorité des français ont le sentiment
que vos réformes ne s'adresse pas à eux
et n'amélioreront pas leur situation
mais justement eh bien il faut continuer
à faire cette pédagogie et je vous
remercie de pouvoir nous permettre de le
faire dans sur les plateaux comme on le
fait on le fait ce soir parce que nos
politiques elle s'adresse à tout le
monde elle ne laisse personne sur le
bord du chemin madame parce que tout
simplement c'est que nous avons besoin
c'était cette théorie des premiers de
cordée canon a parlé emmanuel macron il
ya les premiers de cordée ils doivent
entraîner les autres et nous nous sommes
là pour entraîner aussi le peuple
français derrière des mesures qui soient
acceptables pour tous derrière des
mesures qui soient précises mais qui
soit juste qui soit juste socialement
qu'ils soient justes fiscalement et qui
permettent aussi de créer les conditions
d'un environnement économique qui
permette de créer de l'emploi qui
permettent de redonner de la
compétitivité dans les dans les
entreprises et qui permettent à la fin
des fins et bien de redonner de l'emploi
pour nos concitoyens c'est de redonner
des moyens dans l'éducation pour former
nos jeunes c'est de redonner des moyens
et puisque je suis ministre de la
culture c'est notre culture est l'état
des poumons économiques de notre pays et
c'est ce qui doit être super bien pas de
discours en de défense des manuels
macron de quelque chose que vous avez
raté durant ces six premiers mois je ne
me pose pas la question comme ça
peut-être que parfois il faut faire
preuve de plus de pédagogie expliquer
pourquoi nous faisons pourquoi nous
faisons les choses
vous savez on a besoin de temps pour
dresser des premiers bilans et je crois
que ce n'est pas au bout de six mois que
on peut on peut toujours corriger une
trajectoire vous allez dans les jus
style présidentiel son autorité est ce
que vous vous sentez vous même un peu
pas tenus en laisse en puisque tout
remonte à l'elysée du temps non pas du
toit que moi je me sens je ne me sens
pas tenu je ne parle pas d'autorité non
il fait autorité
il fait autorité parce qu'il incarne la
fonction la fonction présidentielle et
le président de la république il a su
entraîner derrière lui d'abord il a
gagné l'élection présidentielle
donc c'est une capacité à pouvoir
entraîner les gens derrière soient
derrière un programme derrière des
propositions il n'en fait pas un peu
trop est-ce que vous ministre vous avez
des marges de manoeuvre et bien sûr nous
travaillons tous les jours nous sommes à
notre tâche et nous rendons des comptes
et c'est bien normal
un ministre doit rendre doit rendre des
comptes et je le fais à chaque fois que
cela mais mes demandes et et sans aucune
difficulté
et tous mes collègues en font en photo
temps et c'est bien et c'est bien normal
mais rendre des comptes
c'est aussi avoir cette capacité à
pouvoir dire les choses dire ce qui va
dire ce qui ne va pas faire des
propositions et ensuite il ya des
arbitrages
moi je n'ai pas d'états d'âme d'accord
pas d'état d'âme le juste pour finir sur
sur cette question il ya le dernier
conseil des ministres a duré plus
longtemps que prévu à ce qu'elle ait eu
un recadrage de la part des manuels
macron n'ont eu plus de recadrage et on
vous a dit ça suffit les fuites
il a il n'y a pas eu de je vous dis
qu'il n'ya pas eu de recadrage
au nom de la république nous a appelés à
nous concentrer sur notre tâche à
travailler a expliqué ce que nous
faisons à faire preuve de pédagogie et
il a duré longtemps parce que comme vous
le savez dans les grands lacs au conseil
des ministres il ya beaucoup de sujets
abordés et il y à des débats et chacun a
la possibilité de pouvoir s'exprimer et
c'est pourquoi ces conseils des
ministres et bien il dure longtemps mais
il dure longtemps mais parce qu'ils sont
utiles vacallo regarde juste avant de
passer à christophe castaner vous êtes
un élu local stéphane travert parmi ce
qu'on retient de ces six mois du bilan
d' emmanuel macron c'est cette colère
des élus locaux est ce que vous vous la
comprenez cette colère d'abord toujours
faire de la pédagogie je peux je peux
comprendre que les élus locaux puissent
parfois se sentir éloigné des des
centres de décision moi je vis je suis
issu du modèle d'un milieu très très
rurale et je vois bien cette différence
qu'il peut y avoir entre les villes les
eaux des grandes zones urbaines les
métropoles et les zones les zones
rurales
mais aujourd'hui notre travail c'est
quoi et bien c'est d'essayer de faire en
sorte que nous puissions rassembler tout
cela et veillez à ce que aussi bien en
milieu rural qu'en en zone urbaine
chacun puisse avoir les mêmes chances et
la même capacité à pouvoir innover à
réfléchir et apporter des projets alors
christophe castaner on va et vient
prendre la tête de la république en
marche dans dix jours il est le seul
candidat
est ce que c'est le fait du prince non
ce n'est pas le fait du prince il a été
choisi par un collectif et nous avons
pensé que christophe castaner parce
qu'il faisait partie de celles et ceux
qui ont la confiance des adhérents du
mouvement
christophe castaner a été avec non mais
sûr que non c'est un collectif qui a
choisi la candidature de christophe
castaner east of castaner fait partie
des tout premiers à avoir rejoint le
mouvement avoir rejoint emmanuel macron
nous étions quelques-uns nous étions
même avec christophe cartin castaner
nous partageons et les chars ferrand au
groupe nous partageons le fait d'avoir
été rapporteur de la loi macron
en 2015 et tout a commencé tout a
commencé ici et aujourd'hui christophe
castaner est totalement légitime pour
incarner notre mouvement notre mouvement
politique et faire de la république en
marche un beau mouvement de respiration
démocratique un beau mouvement de
réflexion politique des 2es complète
chef de parti est resté secrétaire
d'état aux relations avec le parlement
oui bien sûr cela c'est cela s'est vu
plus compliqué pour le porte parole a
bien évidemment parce que ce qu'il lui
il sera amené à le quitter mais moi je
souhaite après ce n'est pas moi qui
prends la décision ne me regarde pas
mais je pense qu'il est tout légitime
leur blesse pas à moi de le dire parce
que de toute façon ce n'est pas à moi de
prendre cette décision inquiète beaucoup
de références mais je n'ai pas afficher
de préférence vous savez le chef de
l'état et le premier ministre ont feront
un choix et ce choix sera le mien
d'accord vous êtes socialiste stéphane
travert strauss kahn a je suis toujours
socialiste mais socialiste être
socialiste n'est pas juste avoir un bout
de carton et être adhérent d'un parti
des socialistes c'est une culture c'est
ce sont des valeurs c'est une identité
oui je suis de gauche et et je ne
là-dessus je n'ai pas je n'ai pas changé
alors dominique strauss kahn a déclaré
ce week end à marrakech je crois qu'il
n'y a pas d'avenir pour le ps c'est une
bonne chose il est temps qu'ils
disparaissent est ce que vous êtes
d'accord
je crois que le ps doit se refonder
complètement le ps a perdu la bataille
de l'opinion la bataille des idées le ps
ne ne travaillait plus ne portait plus
l'espoir de ces de ses concitoyens mais
de la même manière le parti l air est
exactement dans la même dans la même
situation
je crois que les valeurs de gauche elles
peuvent aujourd'hui s'incarner
différemment il nous sommes quelques-uns
à pouvoir le faire en vous oppose bien
sûr souvent on l'a fait dans cette
émission à nicolas hulot il a annoncé
dans une interview au monde c'était une
nulle c'est un ultimatum à gérer
vous direz dans un an si j'ai été utile
auquel cas je resterai est ce que vous
vous dites la même chose je verrai dans
un an si j'ai été utile sinon j'aime à
cirer mais vous savez moi je ne pose pas
le débat en ces termes c'est derrière
moi de décider si je reste ou si je le
mets vous avez votre collègue qui le dit
pour lui même et aller nous je ne me
choque pas moi c'est chacun voit midi à
sa porte comme on dit ici mais en ce qui
me concerne ce que vous voyez pas
toujours la même chose et non mais se
redresse et que c'était pas moi qui
décide si je reste je pars donc les
choses sont assez claires
bon alors time magazine the next leader
aux violences dites donc c'est manuel
macron il écrit en tout petit si
seulement il parvient à diriger la
france
est-ce qu'il va réussir là bien sûr mais
je n'exclus d europe c'est tabou titre
reste une belle photo très bien vous y
croyez on a compris ce que je suis un
bâtisseur merci beaucoup merci dorian
merci monsieur le ministre vincent riou
à la semaine prochaine mais tôt
[Musique]